in the new book good cops he spoke about
it recently at Roosevelt University in
Chicago for an hour 20 minutes hi good
evening my name is Heather dolmage and I
am the director of the Mansfield
Institute for social justice here at
Roosevelt University and I just want to
say a couple of words about the
Mansfield Institute and then I'll be
introducing Terry Johnson who will
introduce our speaker tonight professor
David Harris this year the Mansfield
Institute has been very active we have
done done work in the area of sexuality
and social justice we've done stuff on
the reparations movement we had a one
book one University where we invited all
members of the Roosevelt community to
read Barbara Ramsey's book Ella Baker in
the black freedom movement and then we
hosted weekly book discussions and it
culminated a couple weeks ago with the
Mansfield lectureship Barbara ramsby
came to speak about the book and it was
a wonderful event we will be doing the
one book one University again next year
and we are open to nominations so please
if you have books that you think are of
interest in the area of social justice
let us know we are very happy to be
hosting a conversation with Professor
Harris again tonight he came in the fall
for a series that we worked with Hull
House and Terry Johnson on race and
criminalization so we are happy that he
is back with us again tonight I would
again before we before David speaks I
would like to introduce Terry Johnson
she is Terry Johnson is the vice
president of public policy reform and
advocacy at Hull House and she is going
to come up now to say some words about
professor Harris and a one-one side note
or shall I say sidebar one side note the
bookstore is here with professor
Harris's books and they will be here
until 6:15 so if you want to purchase
the books just make sure that you do so
and then he will be signing books
afterwards and we have refreshments
please
help yourself they're in the back of the
room thank you Thank You Heather
I add my good evening to all of you and
thank you for coming out
we have as Heather said worked with the
Mansfield Institute for a couple of
programs about race and criminalization
and the reason we do that is the Jane
Addams Hall House Association has for
the last 115 years been committed to the
notion that in order to change the
people lives that we serve we have to
change the conditions in which they find
themselves so we have for the last four
years been taking a more intensive
systemic analysis of how these systems
impact the lives of our clients and so
in order to do that one of the systems
we looked at was the criminal justice
system I have known David Harris for
almost eight years actually based on
some work that we've done before in
other cities around the very question of
racial profiling and so I am honored to
yet again bring David before you because
not only is he an expert in his field
but he's also truly committed to making
some changes in this system so let me
give you a little bit of information
about David before I ask him to join me
at the podium
he is the bought professor of law and
values at the University of Toledo
College of Law and indeed is the
nation's leading authority on racial
profiling his book Profiles and
injustice why racial profiling cannot
work was published in 2002 to wide
acclaim in the mainstream media he is
also the author of the first and the
most influential scholarly articles
published on the subject and helped
representative John Conyers introduced
the federal traffic stops statistics Act
of 1997 try saying that fast the Act
which is actually based on David's work
was the first legislative proposal at
any level to attack the problem of
racial profiling and is the model for
many laws throughout the nation and in
particularly more than 20 states for
data collection efforts and hundreds and
for those of you who don't know this
Illinois is actually working on some
legislation at the state level that's
going to help us track racial profiling
David works widely with the media on
racial profiling criminal justice and
policing issues and in his new book he
showcases police departments that have
proven that we actually can have
effective policing without racial
profiling and therefore have respectful
and proper treatment of all of our
citizenry but no further ado I present
to you David Harris thank you thank you
so much Terry and Heather it's a great
pleasure to be here my thanks to the
Mansfield Institute for sponsoring our
event this evening and to the Jane
Addams Hull House it's great honor to be
associated with them and to come in as
their guest and it's great to see all of
you here tonight I'm going to talk about
a common conception in our country you
know it's widely believed that if a
person if a citizen wants to be safe in
this country if you want to be safe from
criminals if you want safe streets you
want to be safe from terrorists you have
to be willing to give up your rights
under the Constitution you have to be
willing to give the police more room to
give them greater latitude because
that's the only way that we can really
ensure our safety well as Benjamin
Franklin said so long ago those who
would give up liberty for safety deserve
neither one but I want to take it a
little bit further in our modern world
and say this it is not necessary for us
to give up the best of who we are as
Americans in order to be safe either
from criminals or terrorists my work
over the last five years has taken me
all over the country large cities and
small towns big police departments and
sheriff's departments and all kinds of
law enforcement agencies with different
missions and I have seen that there is
another way that this trade-off the
require
of a trade-off of your civil liberties
for safety is a myth and it's one that I
want to expose by telling you the
stories of the police departments that
are doing something different because by
observing them and in the course of
writing this book writing about them I
came to see that it is not just possible
it is happening now we are having we are
in an era where we can have effective
policing when I say effective policing I
mean policing that is effective against
crime that cuts crime at the same time
that it respects citizens those two
things are not in opposition in fact
they go hand in hand
so I'd like to start tonight by telling
you a story right here from Chicago
where we are tonight this is the story
about a man named Anthony Scalise
Anthony Scalise is a sergeant in the
Chicago Police Department he's been with
the police department for almost four
decades and Anthony Scalise was named in
1991 to the Civil Rights unit of the
Chicago Police Department and his
particular charge was to take action
against hate crimes I think you know
many police departments many many police
officers even might regard this
assignment as a backwater maybe a
demotion something like that but Scalise
knew better and he immediately seized
upon the possibilities in his job it's
important to remember that in 1991 the
concept of hate crimes was rather new
that this was something that people had
not thought about much before in big
city police departments the idea that if
you commit a crime that is motivated by
racial or religious or ethnic bias that
that is something special something a
little different and that it requires
different kinds of enforcement and maybe
ultimately different kinds of punishment
so Scalise
really
took his assignment and grabbed it and
ran with it and he began by doing the
things that make this kind of policing
work preventive policing Scalise began
to meet with all of the minority groups
in Chicago of course he met with people
in the african-american community in the
Latino communities
Chicago of course a very diverse City
more than one Latino community they come
from many different places and he didn't
stop there he also met with many of the
religious groups even some religious
groups that were newer to Chicago and in
each instance he met with these groups
he went out of his way he talked to them
he came to their meetings in each case
his message was the same we're here to
help you we want to know if you've
experienced an incident of bias or
biased crime a hate crime you come to us
we'll help you be our partners will be
your partners and he worked at this very
steadily over the years and had a lot of
success building relationships building
partnerships all as a way of setting up
preventive measures now I want to take
you kind of fast forward to the July 4th
weekend of 1999 this particular weekend
some of you in Chicago may remember this
Scalise got a call in the early evening
he was told come right up immediately to
West Rogers Park or been a shooting and
when he got there he found that there
were six shooting victims six people
who've been shot from a moving car and
he knew right away why he'd been called
as soon as he got there because he saw
the victims there all of them were in
distinctive Orthodox Jewish dress this
is in a Jewish community it was Friday
night the victims all seem to be headed
towards one of the neighborhood
synagogues
it looked like a bias crime it looked
like a hate crime right away and as soon
as he got there he talked to one of his
officers and they told him they had a
problem the problem was the victims
wouldn't talk to the police
nobody in the neighborhood who might
have seen something would talk to the
police
and Scalise knew why because of his long
work with the Jewish community he
understood this he knew it was Friday
night the beginning of the Jewish
Sabbath he knew that observant Jews on
Friday night all the way through the
Sabbath do not do anything that might be
construed as work and because of that
they were not going to talk to municipal
officials even police officers that
might be seen as work now as soon as
this realization set in almost the same
moment another call came in over the
police radio system there had been
another shooting in the nearby suburb of
Skokie a black man outside had been shot
this man died and then just a short time
after that another report from the
suburb of Northbrook a group of Asian
people had been shot at and this told
Scalise he had his worst nightmare right
in front of him
a serial hate crime something you hope
never to see but there it was and he
knew he needed information and he needed
it right now he also knew that until the
Jewish Sabbath ended there would be no
work and therefore no information now he
didn't know what to do about this but he
knew who to call he called a man named
Moshe Wolfe Moshe Wolff is a rabbi lived
in that community was also an Orthodox
Jew he was a chaplain still is as far as
I know a chaplain for the Chicago Police
Department Scalise went to Wolfe he
filled him in
is it can you help me can you help me
can you do something and wolf knew
exactly what to do he went right to the
scene right to where he could find the
victims right to where he could find the
witnesses and he talked to them wolf is
a rabbi he knew exactly what to say
he took the people aside and he
explained to them a Jewish concept
called Baku of nefesh but Kulik nefesh
translates roughly as a matter of life
and death and rabbi wolf explained to
these folks yes we keep the Sabbath we
observe it strictly but a matter of life
and death takes precedence and this is
one of those times and with rabbi Wolf's
encouragement the victims came forward
they went to the 24th district they gave
information about the shooter the car it
was the first fragmentary but the first
description of the shooter and the
vehicle and for the first time the
police were able to match that
information to information that came
from the other shootings they realized
they had the same person and it turned
into a crucial break in the case that
allowed the police to track this shooter
all the way down to downstate Illinois
where they later cornered him it turned
out he was a follower of Matthew Hale of
the World Church of the Creator the
white supremacist Church his name was
Benjamin Smith and it was because
Scalise had a partner it was because he
knew who to go to
that this case took the fortunate turn
that it did that is preventive policing
that is the way police departments can
go in the future to get ahead of crime
to be effective against crime and at the
same time to work with the public to
have them
as partners this idea that police need
more room and citizens need less
constitutional protection in order for
us to be safe Scalise is the proof that
that's not so and in this is not a
theory this is in practice it's on the
ground it's working its effective and
it's measurable preventive policing can
be the future so let me take a few
minutes and tell you just what
preventive policing is there are five
core principles to preventive policing
and if we understand that I think we'll
get a good grip on why it is such an
innovation why it's such an opportunity
first first core principle is building
bridges
this is Scalise building bridges
building partnerships and relationships
with the community so that when the time
comes they're there to be taken
advantage of and used this facilitates
communication and there is simply
nothing more important than
communication because the communication
it takes place between the community
served and the police who serve them
bring lots of important crime-fighting
pieces of information to the police and
they give the police the opportunity to
learn what the community's priorities
are number two problem solving when I
say problem solving what I mean is a
strategy of policing that doesn't focus
on individual incidents it's very easy
in today's world to to talk about how
overwhelmed police are with constant 911
with constant needs to respond and they
are overwhelmed they have more to do
than they can handle
problem solving policing takes a
different approach instead of seeing
each crime as an individual discrete
incident
problem-solving policing looks at the
whole picture pulls back and says well
why do we get so many calls from this
particular corner why so many 911 calls
from this apartment building let's
analyze the data let's look at the crime
patterns over the last 24 months who
were the people involved who were the
victims who were the perpetrators when
we caught them what seemed to be the
patterns here by focusing on patterns
police can devise solutions that will
actually cut down on the number of 911
calls over the long run it will actually
reduce crime and sometimes even
eliminate it from the hot spots in every
city in town
third accountability accountability both
external and internal I cannot emphasize
this strongly enough this is really the
linchpin of so many efforts to reform
and improve policing in so many cities
around the country
when I say external accountability what
I mean is accountability to citizens
when citizens file a complaint is there
an institution a mechanism a device in
place to handle complaints in an
independent way that citizens will trust
when I say internal accountability what
I'm talking about
are new kinds of mechanisms that have
come in to policing over the last 10
years the one that is the most important
in my mind is something we call an early
warning system an early warning system
is a way to use computer technology to
bring discrete pieces of information
about police behavior all together have
them all in one place in one information
system so that way the chief the captain
the lieutenant all the way down to the
sergeant can know what police are doing
individually and contract that behavior
now you'd expect things like citizens
complaints to be measured this way and
tracked this way you might expect thing
such as automobile accidents uses of
force shootings whatever it turns out to
be but there are lots of other things
that go into these systems to Mister
court dates sick days outside employment
all of this creates a total picture of
where any individual officer is at and
when the lieutenant the sergeant the
captain sees signs of trouble they can
nip that trouble in the bud they can get
the officer retrained they can get the
officer counsel they can send the
officer to substance abuse treatment
whatever it takes they can get things
back on track and what if what it takes
is nudging somebody into another line of
work they might be able to do that too
leadership changes for many many years
police leadership has been same-old
same-old in a military-style
organization you know police have ranks
there are lines of authority there are
reporting systems don't go over the
captain's head to the next guy and
increasingly there are new leaders in
police leaders who adapt and who have to
have brought to policing a different
style and a key ingredient here is
openness an openness to new ideas and
openness to outsiders and most most
different of all a willingness to share
power in police organizations for many
many years
the idea was accumulate power for
yourself no matter what your position
was you don't want to give it away and
an increasing number of Chiefs are
seeing that the thing to do is to give
their subordinates power along with
accountability and responsibility this
is a sea change in law enforcement
number five changes in police culture
this may be the toughest nut to crack of
all you know police culture is
notoriously insular police organizations
are famous for excluding the ideas and
views of outsiders there's a real
feeling that
you haven't worn the uniform or carried
the badge you don't know what the job is
like and you really have no right to
criticize I understand where that comes
from it is a singular kind of job but
ultimately it's a job in a democratic
society in which the public has to be
served this realization that is dawning
on an increasing number of police
departments is what is driving changes
in police culture and what I see
could be neatly encapsulated you know in
a nice little analogy I came across I
saw an article by by somebody the title
of it it was about changing police
culture in it then the article said
something like it's changing police
culture will be just as easy as bending
granite easy bending granite and I get
it
you know there's there's something to
that but what I also see is that now we
could not we could regard police culture
not as granite but maybe is wood wood is
hard wood is firm but wood can be bent
if you take the time you apply the
pressure correctly a strong straight
piece of wood can become the beautiful
curving wood of the guitar or a violin
and that's the kind of thing it will
take to change police culture strong
consistent pressure over a long time a
demand that things be done in a new and
better way and now that there are models
out there this is no longer a pipe dream
so those are the five core ideas
building bridges solving problems
accountability leadership changes and
changes in police culture I think what
I'd like to do is to just illustrate one
of these for you using something I saw
while I was researching and writing the
book because when you go out and you
look at these police departments
and you see what they're actually doing
it really is remarkable it really shows
you that change is possible in an area
where we often thought it was hopeless
so let me take a few minutes and tell
you about Stamford Connecticut Stamford
Connecticut this is a medium-sized city
outside of New York and in the middle to
late 90s they got a new chief Chiefs
name is Dean Esserman
chief Esserman
was known as an original thinker in
policing a person who was open to ideas
so one of the reasons I like this story
is it brings a number of different
principles together one of the things
that chief Esserman did when he started
in Stanford was he began a school police
officer program lots of communities have
these programs they are formally known
as SRO program school resource officer
programs there is funding available
there's training available there are
standards things like that set out by
federal agencies and organizations
Esserman liked this idea he liked the
fact that police would be able to
connect with the children in the
community that they'd be able to connect
with the community through the schools
and he decided he wanted to have a
program of school resource officers in
his town so he picked out his officers
and the people he wanted for this
program he did not go for what you might
think as you know the conventional
choices he didn't look for people who
had maybe special skills with kids he
went for his toughest biggest most
experienced cops cops and two of the
many came up with were Scott Baldwin and
John Jeter they're fascinating guys
Baldwin had been on the dive team of the
department he'd been in a SWAT unit I
mean this was an action-oriented police
officer
no mistaking it John Jeter had been in
Newark in the narcotics squad for 15
years very successful and so nobody
could say that these were cops who
couldn't do the whole job that's why a
sermon wanted them that's why he
selected them well these officers along
with eight others went into the Stanford
schools and the program was an immediate
success the community loved it schools
loved it and the kids loved it but maybe
most surprising the cops loved it the
police officers just loved it and you
talked to John Jeter about this and he
he says you know this this was the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
I was in narcotics for 15 years I was
you know out there on the street I was
making a bus here I got a chance to
prevent future crime I got a chance to
get ahead and that's just not something
you can do when you're around the
narcotics squad John Jeter was posted to
a middle school and he became one of the
most popular police officers in Stanford
well he went through his first year well
into the second year and chief Esserman
held a meeting with the school resource
officers toward the end of that second
year he held periodic meetings with all
his officers so he'd get to see them
talk to them take take stock of their
experience get their ideas and he was
known as being an original thinker in a
kind of open-minded chief so when chief
Esserman
said to the school resource officers at
this meeting what are you going to do
this summer
John Jeter decided to take a chance
because he had a wild idea he decided to
let this idea out and see how the chief
reacted to it he said chief how about we
start a summer camp how about we have a
summer camp for the kids in my school
and he explained you know he said you
know these are middle school kids the
ones who go to summer school will go to
summer school till noon every day by the
time it's noon
it's too late for them to go to the
regular camps they all start in the
morning they're too young to get summer
jobs the too old for the daycare stuff
so what happens to them loose on the
street loose at home parents still at
work it's a recipe for disaster
I want to figure out something we can do
for my kids my kids he says hundreds of
my kids and I want to have a camp we
could have it here at school we can give
the kids lunch you know we'll do
something with them we'll figure it out
now I think that in most police
departments the idea of let's run a
summer camp for middle schoolers might
have seemed crazy I think a lot of
Chiefs would have reacted badly to this
what are you nuts we're cops we're not
camp counselors what do you think this
is but estimate is a different kind of
chief and his reaction instantly was
let's do it this is a great idea and he
said about building on the relationships
that he had already cultivated in his
two or so years as chief he went to the
mayor and got a commitment of city funds
so that they could hire high school kids
and college kids as counselors pay him a
good wage give him something to put on a
resume give him training he went to a
local foundation a Domus foundation this
foundation had been sponsoring youth
programs in Stanford for a long time
they were the right organization because
they could supply the administrative
structure for the camp as you know
police don't really know how to run a
camp but these people do they went to
the to the City School District they got
the district to commit the use of one of
their buildings they got the bus service
committed and they got private sector
money to fill out the picture and last
but not least a sermon ever the taker of
chances he takes his drug forfeiture
money which is supposed to go to buy
fancy equipment for his department says
just going into camp and I don't care
what you say about it
and so the camp was often running in his
first year it serviced a hundred kids
the next year more the year after that
even more by the third year was taking
every kid in town that wanted to be in
this camp I visited this camp it was
really something to see you know the
kids are well occupied they're doing all
the things that you do in a camp some
are taking martial arts and some are
doing computers and some are doing arts
and crafts and some are outside playing
ball but they all are doing something
and they all are doing it with people
who can be good strong adult role models
and it was really something to see all
these high school kids the college kids
they all had good jobs for the summer
there was competition to get these jobs
after the first year it was a real
success so you ask yourself how is this
crime fighting how does this fight crime
it's a legitimate question after the
first two years the United States
Department of Justice Unit came in and
did an evaluation of the camp they found
that kids were more able to resist gang
recruitment drug use had better
relationships with the police and that
the police had better relationships not
only with the kids but with the parents
and the community that the relationships
that had flowered during the school year
actually got even better but again you
ask yourself show me that it works for
cutting crime is this crime fighting or
is it social work is it camp counseling
well let me show you we have a very
interesting opportunity to learn
something from this experience because
after the first several years that the
camp was in operation in 2002 the bottom
fell out of the economy
and Stamford Connecticut as it did in
many other cities in the country private
sector money for the camp completely
dried up the city administration had no
extra money all the school district
could do would be to commit what was to
commit the school building and even the
foundation the Domus foundation was
unable to do anything but a kind of
scaled-down effort and so when the camp
was looking at the summer of 2003 things
looked pretty bleak and what they
decided that they wanted to do was to
preserve the structure of the camp but
it would have to be in a much
scaled-down sighs so the camp of 2003
was less than 20 percent the size of the
camp of 2002 they were down to about 35
kids and these were the 35 kids were
most at risk that we're going to the
at-risk summer program and what this
does for us standing back now is it
gives us an opportunity to ask a pretty
interesting question no it's not a
controlled experiment but if we can get
the numbers we can actually see what
difference the camp might have made so
let me show you some of these numbers
in the summer of 2001 in Stanford there
were 69 arrests of juveniles kids in
this age bracket for two hundred and
thirty six crimes in the summer of 2002
the trajectory which had been started
actually before what you see here was
clearly downward for only fifty seven
arrests for a hundred and seventy five
total crimes now we look at 2003 the
year in which the camp was vastly scaled
back a hundred and five juvenile arrests
for four hundred and fourteen separate
crimes now I'm not going to stand up
here and make the logical mistake of
saying just because something happened
after it happened because of but I have
looked and looked I have to tell you
four other explanations of why crime
suddenly spiked up in this age group in
this particular summer and I can't find
one it seems at least a question worth
asking at least something worth
exploring and I'm hoping that as we go
forward to 2005 the camp is going to be
up and running again at full strength
because this was a perfect example of
problem solving by a police officer
Jeter looks out he sees a problem he
sees hundreds of kids with nothing to do
for five hours a day before at least
some of their parents come home between
12:00 and 5 he knows that's the most
crime prone hours for this age group
this is when kids get into trouble he
looks at the whole picture and he says
what would change this and what would
allow me to solidify my relationships
with my kids and he comes up with this
idea the camp
this is problem-solving and preventive
policing at its absolute finest and it's
rightly regarded as a national example
of the kind of things that police can do
when they're allowed creativity when
they're told big picture
take a look ahead prevent don't just
react so much of our policing for so
long has been about reacting to crime
reacting after its occurred now that
will never go away they're always going
to be emergencies it's always going to
be 911 police respond to that's never
going to go away but what we can look
forward to with preventive policing is a
future where that's not all the police
do and they put an increasing amount of
effort to reducing crime over the long
haul in ways that will frankly make for
fewer emergencies as we go on now let's
talk about today's world and the
question that's on everybody's mind what
about terrorism does preventive policing
have a role in preventing terrorism how
is it stack up there and the short
answer is preventive policing prevention
is what the whole effort is about with
terrorism that's what the whole game is
you know I hope that they will catch
Osama bin Laden at some point I hope
that will happen I hope he faces justice
for what he did I hope all the people
that helped him do that will face
justice but frankly the damage is done
whether they catch him or not
what would be really good is to be able
to head off further terrorist attacks
prevent them whether we catch people
afterwards when the damage has been done
much better to catch him beforehand so
prevention is the right focus and it
turns out that preventive policing is
exactly the strategy
that can do this for us and that
reactive types of policing don't help at
all and in fact may even hurt us now
when we say preventive policing and
terrorism the most important thing the
most a number one issue for preventive
policing for prevention of terrorism is
information I don't mean anything fancy
here you can call it intelligence if
you're the CIA and the National Security
Agency
I mean information in the sense that
police officers use that word on the
ground you want to know what's going on
in your community you have to talk to
the people in your community you have to
have relationships with them you have to
have a two-way information conduit
between the people you serve and the
people doing the serving information is
the key the absolute essential to
heading off terrorism think about it I
mean if we have sleeper cells on our
soil right now if there are cells in
this country made up of middle-eastern
adherents of Osama bin Laden if they're
there and a government says they are
what we need is information there are
only a couple of ways to figure out what
these people are up to one is
infiltrating them but since the FBI has
fired all its arabic-speaking agents and
has trouble with its translators and
just can't recruit people from these
communities that's out so we have one
choice there is only one possibility for
getting this information just one we
have to get it from the communities
themselves they are the people who know
the language they are the people who
know the culture they are the people who
understand the nuances of what people
say and how they express themselves
who's moving in who's moving out who's
keeping a low profile
some odd way who's got suspicious
opinions whatever it happens to be the
people in the community are the only
ones that we can turn to now we need the
middle eastern communities like we have
never needed anyone in fact for
prevention of terrorism how are we going
to accomplish this preventive policing
build those bridges solve problems with
the community be accountable to them you
make a mistake say so when you have
statistics that show the performance of
your department put them out there let
the public react to them take complaints
seriously and hold your officers
accountable for them those are the
things that will allow people to begin
to trust you
and to treat you as a partner if you're
the police department and that's what
will bring you the information and
frankly it's the only thing that can
bring you the information because if the
people in the community don't trust the
police they'll fear the police and that
will break down that conduit of
information let me give you an example
of how this works we're all familiar I
hope with the cell that was broken in
Lackawanna New York this is claimed by
the Department of Justice to be the
single biggest victory in the war on
terror on American soil Lackawanna is a
small town outside of Buffalo New York
it is it has a very large population of
people who came from Yemen and when the
cell hit the newspapers when the fact of
these arrests hit the newspapers there
was some information that was not
noticed sometimes even left out as some
of these reports how did the government
break the lock Awana cell was it FBI
wiretap was it the CIA was it the
National Security
see intercepting communications and
emails and so forth no none of that the
way the government broke this case was
the community itself members of the
Yemeni community came to law enforcement
before law enforcement was even aware
that there might be a problem in little
Lackawanna New York the community
the Yemeni community came to them
including that came to the community
policing officer for this town the
person they knew and they said look six
or seven young guys they seemed okay
they play soccer but we think you should
know all of them went to Camp Osama last
summer we don't know what this is about
we don't you know none of us were there
but you should know because maybe you
want to look into this that was the key
break in the case without that this
doesn't even occur there's no break in
the case and for all we know that cell
is still operating so prevention turns
out to be the absolute key aspect in
fighting terrorism and it's often
overlooked now that would be a great
place to be able to stop and say it's
the future you know this is where we're
going yes they'll always be emergencies
and things like that we'll always have
to respond in some way but preventive
policing is the way to get ahead of
crime this is clearly how we can make
our communities better how we can tie
the communities and police together how
we can have policing that is effective
that does not force us to make that
compromise of giving up what's best
about being an American and I wish that
that was really all I had to
about all of this but it's not you know
when you when you do a project like this
when you write a book you have to be
prepared to be surprised you have to be
prepared to learn things maybe you
didn't expect and that happened to me I
was moving around the country I was
visiting police departments I was going
here and going there seeing some very
impressive police work but about a year
and a half ago about two years ago I
began to hear something I didn't expect
and it came from Chiefs it came from
captains it came from patrol officers on
the street they began to tell me
something that I did not expect they
said we've got a problem because there
is a counter trend there is something
else happening here we've got the
federal government asking that we do
some things that don't seem all that
smart to us and what they're trying to
do is instead of taking up these new
positive initiatives they're beginning
to rely on the old style traditional
dragnet types of enforcement and the
federal government does not seem to be
aware or even care that we the local
police the people on the ground
understand how to police in an immigrant
community understand how to grab up
intelligence and have relationships
instead they're going back to the bad
old ways of the bad old days and they
want to take us with them and I was
really kind of surprised to hear this
but I got example after example from
them let's give you one or two this
counter-trend can be seen most clearly
in federal efforts to force local police
into immigration work
there's a big problem in this country as
you know with immigration immigration
system is broken it's broken
everybody agrees what the federal
government wants to do is to take local
police and State Police and use them as
a quote force multiplier to use them as
adjuncts to the inss or whatever the I
NS is called now in their new homeland
security guys they want local police to
enforce immigration law on behalf of the
federal government and local police know
how dangerous a situation and how crazy
a suggestion that really is they the
federal government want to give any more
training I want to give them any more
funding I'm particularly sensitive to
the idea of training I'm a law professor
I don't teach immigration laws not my
area and I would no more give somebody
immigration advice then you know advice
on how to become King of England or
something it's complicated it's like tax
law changes every two years it's
incredibly detailed and they want to
send local police officers out into the
field and have them enforce immigration
law with no training no standards
nothing local police know that this is a
recipe for disaster they have been the
ones who have built the bridges with
their immigrant communities they know
that if they want the streets to be safe
in Chicago or in Austin Texas or in Los
Angeles or in many other places around
the country they have to work with the
immigrant communities whether people are
legal or illegal whether they're in the
country legitimately or not the police
have made efforts in many cities around
the country to have the population
understand have the people understand
that they're not interested in their
immigration status they are interested
in making
them safe local police want to secure
safety for everybody in the city because
they're all human beings matter them
what their legal status is and they know
that if they go out into the community
and they start playing AI NS and they
start arresting people for being out of
status for being illegal the community
will begin to fear them they will stop
reporting crimes in the community they
will stop reporting when even they are
victimized when they are robbery victims
when they are rape victims when they are
victims of domestic violence people
won't come to them they won't call the
police they won't even call the fire
department if they think they're going
to get reported so there's been a real
strong effort over the last five years
by local police in many places to show
the immigrant communities we're on your
side we don't care about that stuff we
want to make our city safe because we
are all against the Predators who are
out there and what the federal effort to
push local police into immigration work
will do is destroy these efforts set
them back if good policing preventive
policing is about building bridges this
will be about burning bridges and once
that's done you can't get it back other
examples the federal government's effort
to question 5,000 young men from the
Arab world where in the United States
began in fall of 2001 another 3,000 in
the fall of 2002 why do they want to
question them well they're not suspects
it's all voluntary they might just might
know something
and while the Attorney General can give
orders to the FBI to go out there and do
this
they asked because they could not force
they asked local police to get involved
too because only the local police would
know their communities well enough to be
able to go into those communities and
find the people the Department of
Justice was seeking
and the local police departments did not
sign up some did but there was a
surprising amount of opposition some of
it out loud some of it very quiet lots
of big city and small town police
chief's saying you know what we don't
want any part of this you got to do this
you go out and do it yourself
we don't want it because this will just
put us on the wrong side and all that
information that we've been getting will
begin to disappear and we just don't
want that and we're going to be the ones
we the local police will be the ones who
in five years or ten years end up on the
wrong side of the lawsuit that gets
brought because of this while you folks
in the Department of Justice go on your
merry way will be trapped in these
failures and you'll probably sue us too
they don't want any part of that so
the net effect here is a disaster on the
Terrorism front
the net effect has been to set back
anti-terrorism work in a big and
noticeable way this is a big loss for
all of us not just for the communities
affected but for anybody really cares
about being safe from terrorism and it's
because the federal government has not
been keen enough to instead of talk to
instead of telling the local police
here's what you're going to do for us
imagine if they'd gone to local police
how do you get into information out of
your inner immigrant communities how do
you build relationships with them we
don't know anybody in the FBI we don't
know anybody in the Muslim community in
Dearborn Michigan how do we do that
wouldn't that have been a good thing but
instead the United States Department of
Justice has charged ahead in precisely
the wrong direction so how do we get
preventive policing you know I want to
leave us with the feeling that there's
something that we can do because I think
there is the first thing you have to do
the first thing that has to happen is
for the public at large to understand
what preventive policing is to
understand what it is so that you can
recognize it and see it in your own
communities when it happens I found this
happening in 30 states cities towns
east-west Midwest south it happens
everywhere but it gets very little
attention what most people know in the
United States is the Giuliani New York
story right you want to cut crime you
want to make the streets safe you have
to do like Rudolph Giuliani did in New
York you got to go out there and be
tough and have zero tolerance and make
lots and lots of arrests for lots of
small offenses because that's will keep
the big offenses
from happening now the media knows that
story and the media is centered in New
York so that's why we all know that
story there are legitimate reasons to
wonder whether that's what was actually
responsible for bringing crime down in
New York that's a different talk for a
different day but what I can tell you
for sure is that there's a new way of
doing things that we don't have to put
up with massive numbers of arrests and
tough tough tough enforcement in order
to have safer streets and I saw the
proof of it over and over and over in
many places in this country so the first
step is to understand it the second is
to support it when you see things like
this happening in your community when
you see police officers come into
community meetings and commit it over
the long term and willing to sit down
and listen to the community when you see
that you need to support it you need to
talk to your City Council people and say
you know the following happened last
week that's good I want to see more of
that
you know the officer got out of his car
and he talked with those five kids on
the corner instead of giving them an
order out of the PA he had a
conversation with them I want to see
more of that that took that took guts to
do that and I want to see more of it
when you do that you have a chance of
getting it and last but not least there
is simply no substitute for demanding it
if we don't demand better police work we
won't get it now
oftentimes that will take the form of
demanding that certain practices stop
that excessive use of force be stopped
that there be new training so that the
worst that policing sometimes brings to
us will go away will be eliminated but
it takes more than that you have to be
able to say not only do I not want this
I want this
and the examples of preventive policing
that I've been talking about are the
kinds of things that everybody in this
country can support and must demand
because that's the only way we're going
to get it now the good thing is I found
lots of police officers and lots of
leaders in police who were willing to do
it but if they don't get support frankly
from us they won't be able to do it so
it takes not just them it takes us to
it's out there it's not a theory it can
be done it's being done and it's
succeeding I'm ready for your questions
thank you
thank you thank you very much we have a
mic that I think will pick up the
questions in the crowd if you have
questions please raise your hand
sure
could you comment professor Harris on
the on the onion unions on police union
work and how that may affect what you
would like to have done question was
about police unions how would it affect
efforts at preventive policing it's very
good question
I said when I was discussing what
preventive policing was about that one
of the most important of the five
principles was accountability and I have
to say that over the long haul police
organizations don't have a great record
for supporting accountability to their
communities that they have often and
harshly fought against efforts like
citizen review boards in many cities
around the country those boards in fact
have a very mixed record sometimes
because of police union opposition and
sometimes because the boards are set up
without what they need to function
correctly such as subpoena powers such
as a budget such as a staff such as
independence most importantly and police
unions in some areas of the country have
been at the forefront of stymieing many
accountability efforts when those
efforts include civilian input now I I'm
not impugning police unions I don't mean
to do that at all there are many labor
issues for which police unions are
critical for police officers the
membership of these unions had
legitimate issues that they need to have
protected in negotiations with the city
in which they operate at the same time
unions have sometimes become a block to
reform to changes that everybody agrees
are needed and I don't think anybody has
an interest in that this goes back to
something else I said
there's a feeling that if you haven't
been on the job you haven't worn the
uniform you don't have standing to
criticize therefore civilian review
really has no place I simply don't agree
with that in fact civilian review is
necessary for the credibility of
policing for the public to believe in
policing to have faith in its police
department to have face that faith that
its officers are in the same team as the
public is that kind of credibility is
crucial and without accountability you
just don't have it
next question this man there's been like
a long history of bad blood so to speak
in negativity between the police and the
residents what are some of the things
they police can do to signal that they
are in fact trying to go about a
different way because there's such a
deep mistrust of the officers and let me
repeat the question that's a great
question in many communities a strong
historical distrust exists between
police and communities and it runs both
ways it really does in a situation like
that what can police departments do to
recover some of that trust - to start
over again if you like to build upon it
in order to make some of these
preventive measures possible it's a very
good question and it's a very difficult
thing to do but it's not impossible I
would point to the example of Boston a
lot has been written about the very
successful efforts in Boston to curb
juvenile homicides with guns but this
was part of a larger picture if you go
back to Boston in the late 80s and early
90s there was really almost no city in
the country in which there was deeper
distrust between police and the
african-american community than in
Boston I bet a lot of you remember the
story of Charles Stewart and his wife
I'll just remind you this was a white
man who's at the hospital with his
pregnant wife also white
he shot his wife in their car shot
himself reported to the police a black
guy jumped out was trying to rob us and
shot us both the police took you know
took his report as gospel and began to
go through Roxbury and all the the other
black neighborhoods in Boston just
turned every young black man upside down
you know just really made a scene of it
and in the end of course what had
happened was the Charles Stewart had
done this and he threw himself over over
a bridge into the Charles River so he
never had to face the consequences but
it was this and a number of other very
very poor incidents that really had
police and community relations in Boston
at a very low point in the early 90s and
then at the same time they began to face
this terrible problem with their kids
killing each other shooting each other
with handguns and there was a hundred
and fifty such killings in one of the
worst years alone and they had no idea
what to do the old methods that you know
going to the neighborhoods with you know
like a bulldozer and frisk everybody and
sweep the corners none that stuff is
working so maybe what it takes is
getting to a point where you're just
searching for answers because what they
came up with was a unique combination of
resources and people they brought
together not just the highest levels of
law enforcement in the city of Police
Department the United States attorney
the district attorney the probation
department which never usually has
anything to do with the police
department believe it or not along with
the faith community the 10-point
coalition a coalition of black ministers
people in a school system lots and lots
of people and they got together and they
said what do we really have here what do
we really have here it was a
problem-solving workshop essentially
that covered many months what they did
was they figured out what the problem
was
took a one step at a time it turned out
you look at the statistics you looked at
the shootings you looked at the
incidents what you had was a hardcore
small number of gang members it wasn't
even all the gang members it was just
10% they were causing all this havoc so
they brought these people around the
table all the people from the community
from law enforcement they put together a
rounded effort they didn't just go out
and round people up what they did was
they created alternatives anybody wants
to get out of the gang life we can find
you a GED program and get you back into
high school and find you a job we can
get you trained we can do something for
you if you want to get out this is your
opportunity with the hardcore 10% those
people were called in a few at a time
they sat in a room with this
high-powered law enforcement team and
they were told in no uncertain terms no
sheriff in town things are going to
change there's going to be no more guns
we catch you with a gun got you're
shooting a gun catch you're shooting at
somebody with a gun you are going to do
federal time will not be down with
people from the neighborhood and the
county jail you will not go into Western
mass into one of those jails you'll be
out some godforsaken place in Montana or
Nevada where you don't know nobody
everybody's bigger than you and they
hate your guts and this got people's
attention within a month these homicides
went directly downward for two and a
half years there were no homicides by
gun between juveniles now they're more
than zero now things have not stayed
that peaceful they're back to a level
that is not tolerable
but is a little more normal than where
they were the point is this folks in the
community and the police thought they
had nothing in common they thought
they'd had it with each other and by
working together to solve the problem by
asking themselves what's the real
problem here they
they had common ground and they were
able to break through all of that Boston
is now one of the places that other
police departments come to to ask how do
we handle a problem like this so it can
be done it takes work it takes
commitment takes patience it takes time
you know you don't get into situations
of deep distress like that overnight you
don't get out of them overnight either
as people who work in that community
where that historic ingrained mistrust
has been there and it takes us a very
long time to even gain the trust to come
into the community to do the work that
we need to do or that we want to do from
the whole house how do we bring these
two people together because we actually
straddle working with the police even
getting the police to acknowledge us
that we're coming into these
developments this community to do good
stuff and the residents are trusting us
to do this stuff without kind of them
thinking we're telling on you we're
telling you what they're doing so where
does it start
because we we seem to get to a point and
then we just stand there you know we
just get a police officer to come in to
show good faith see this is officer
so-and-so and she's working with us from
CPD but that's as far as it goes
that police officer can't then take it
back to a bigger arena even in a station
you know which where she works from to
help us continue to do the work that
needs to be done because primary is what
you're talking about to get the police
to do preventive stuff and to gain the
support and trust of that community it's
almost impossible yes a very good
question I don't want to do too much to
reframe it because I think you really
hit so many things on the head there
first of all let me say in reaction I
honor your service and the work you do
it's extremely difficult you're taking
risks you're going out on a limb
personally and I recognize that and I
honor what you're doing for your
communities and without people like you
know
thing would happen so the first step has
actually already been taken and it's
been taken by you and I think everybody
owes you thanks how do we get past that
it's tough but the only way that that
can happen is if there's real commitment
on the part of the police department
you've shown coming from Hull House
coming from the community
you've shown you're willing to step up
offer your hand get involved it can't
end with the department simply sending
an officer for a meeting that is not
enough if the police department and the
other citizens in this city want to see
real change they want to see crime rates
go down and stay down and they want to
see that happen not just in their own
neighborhoods but across the city in
neighborhoods where they don't live
there has to be a citywide commitment
the police department must must follow
through on those things if they don't it
will fail that's the surest thing I can
tell you so I don't have a real
optimistic message I just say takes work
and the work has to come from both sides
you're doing it let's see some more
question over here
my question has to do with your attitude
that's the wrong word with your view of
the Justice Department's efforts to
involve local police departments in
their work and I was in I was just
wondering if there is any change or if
there's any movement in the in the
Justice Department or the federal
government
to see your point of view and to okay to
adjust or modify those rather stringent
directives that you that you that you
criticized so much sure the question is
is there any change of foot any prospect
of things getting different in terms of
how the Justice Department is seeking to
use and work with local police I do see
a little bit of change but I see it on
the ground
I see it in the FBI field offices I
talked about Dearborn before so it seems
only fair to start there the FBI office
in the Eastern District of Michigan
where Dearborn is near Detroit has been
very active with trying to work with the
Muslim community to do things with them
and in fact I know that the the special
agent in charge of the FBI field office
until recently and the fellow who was
the United States Attorney these are
people who are in the supervisory roles
on the ground they nominated for
instance one of the Arab Americans most
communities most prominent activists for
a special Justice Department award to
recognize the great work he had done
mobilizing his community to work with
the FBI so they wanted to recognize him
to further pull these efforts together
and I'm sorry to report that this did
not work out the way that either of
them hoped the FBI director director
Muller rejected this nomination after it
had been announced for undisclosed
reasons reasons that still aren't
disclosed but of course leave the kind
of patina that this man may have been
somehow vaguely connected with terrorism
is a terrible thing and as you can guess
it really worsened relations in a way
that you almost can't imagine so I see
the people on the ground really trying
to do things better trying to go into
those communities and and create the
relationships and so forth they're not
getting a great deal of support in
Washington from what I can tell now the
obvious question that kind of pops into
your mind is what about now John
Ashcroft is gone Albert Alberto Gonzalez
is the Attorney General maybe things
will improve I see him as a sort of
kinder gentler Attorney General he says
I read that he's reaching out to the
Justice Department senior staff the
career people that scene is a good thing
but you know in his first major policy
address on these questions in the end of
February
he basically announced that he was
supporting every initiative that the
prior Attorney General had put forward
so the best I can tell you on the top
level is wait and see I don't see any
evidence that things have changed yet
your to your to the question from the
lady from hull-house I gathered that
municipal and police leadership is
essential to preventive policing and
then when I hear your story about which
I read about in the book and Stamford
Connecticut
I'm concerned because we are in an era
where municipalities and police
departments frankly are struggling to
come up with enough money just to pay
their police officers and there's a
great aspect of print preventative
policing that frankly requires money and
in in this era how what's your honest
forecast in terms of how do we sell this
to municipal leaders into police leaders
who are struggling to come up with
enough pennies to pay their officers
much less put those officers in
alternative programs or paid for
alternative programs and whatnot it's an
excellent question where is the money
going to come from you know in American
society that's always something we have
to think about and it's a very live
question right now because the federal
budget which is in front of Congress
which came from President Bush some
weeks back that budget supplies a good
deal of seed money for programs like the
ones I've been talking about and for
reasons that really escaped me these
programs and others are on the chopping
block they have been either zero funded
or ninety percent cut things like that
so it's clear that the rescue is not
going to come from the federal
government in fact the opposite is going
to happen how do you sell it you have to
sell it and I don't think it's any it's
any stretch to sell it as public safety
it is public safety
these aren't extras these aren't add-ons
these are ways to create and maintain
public safety over the long run great
example I heard last week I was
listening to the news there is a group
in California that is proposing
mandatory I'm not sorry not mandatory
but universal preschool preschool for
every four-year-old kid it would be
universally available it's now of course
available to those
kanpei but this would make it available
to everybody the strongest supporters of
this of this initiative and it's going
to be on the ballot I understand in
California is a coalition of law
enforcement people the sheriff of LA
County Lee Baca the California police
chiefs Association on and on and on
every top law enforcement official in
the country has you sorry in California
has come out in support of this now it's
going to cost two billion dollars over
ten years I think that was what I heard
I may have the numbers wrong but it cost
a lot of money but for every dollar that
goes into it the state will save more
than two dollars and it will cut down
not only on the dollars needed for
incarcerated juveniles and for trying
their cases in juvenile court it will
cut down a number of adult career
criminals the amount of probation
officers that we need and all this money
can go into other things so it's not so
much a question of well no it is a
question of where do we get the money
but I think properly viewed it's not
where does the money come from it's pay
now or pay later because if we pay now
if we pay for prevention if we do the
smart things for prevention we will get
to pay less later and we'll have safer
streets and fewer career criminals later
on I just think it's incredibly
interesting that you have law
enforcement lining up in support of
preschools that shows you that there's
been a sea change in the way police view
society they know because they're there
every day they watch people coming and
going through the jail's
they know that having people educated is
the way to a decent employable workforce
and to a safer community - great
question
other questions
if anybody else has a question
all right you get the privilege and then
we can and have a reception and a book
signing following a lot of what you
talked about was preventive policing in
immigrant communities where the
assumption is that terrorism is possibly
coming out of immigrant communities but
what about preventive policing when
terrorism is coming out of white
communities such as the case that you
cited initially with Matt Hale and his
followers and what are the you know
where immigrant communities are actually
the target of that terrorism and so what
kind of preventive policing is happening
around the the Tim mcveigh's and the
Matt Hales and that sort of the same
principles apply that's a terrific
question because as you know before
September 11th the greatest terrorist
act terrorism on American soil was
perpetrated by Tim McVeigh
the all-american Army veteran and unless
we pay attention to those communities we
won't get the information we need there
either it's all about information it's
all about connections it's all about
looking at the full picture so that when
somebody is deeply dissatisfied with
their life their treatment by the
government something like this somebody
comes forward now is that going to
happen every time no we can't prevent
all crimes but if we focus these same
kinds of efforts not just on getting
information from this community of that
one but across the board if we make this
the style of policing the manner of
policing the strategies for policing we
use everywhere will be way ahead and
we'll have a better future whether
violence comes out of this group or that
group won't be as important as what
we've done already to put things in
place to help us when the time comes I
thank you all it's been a real pleasure
I thank the Mansfield Institute and Hull
House for hosting the event thank you
very much thank you
thank you David Harris is a law
professor at the university of toledo
college of law good cops the case for
preventive policing is published by the
new press on the web at the new press